this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's back taking
another look at the weapons from escape
from tarkov and as always we like to
throw him a little curveball oh dave
what have you done to this poor innocent
glock 18 from what i can see under all
of this nonsense it's it's a good
representation of an 18c if you want to
see more of jonathan reaction to escape
from tarkov's guns make sure to
subscribe and check out the previous
videos we made on the game's extensive
arsenal and if you'd like to help the
royal army's museum and continue to
support jonathan's work check out the
links in the description of this video
right over to jonathan
all right we've got the uh the adar i
think it's probably pronounced i've
never actually heard it said out loud
ar15 this may look cursed but it is also
real so the standard version of this uh
pretty generic ar-15 is not equipped
with a pseudo svd set of furniture as we
see here but the company it's a russian
company does indeed offer this set of
furniture as an option as i say it's
real i don't know whether to be
horrified or excited about it maybe both
you've got so many of the iconic
features of the ar the triangular front
sight post this this still has the carry
handle fitted as well so it's kind of
recognizably very m16 smashed into a svd
dragon of and i don't think i can be
angry at it
i suppose a quick comment on on the
handling as it were the virtual handling
of this i can't remember if this is the
case for ars in tarkov generally but
there seems to be a bit too much recoil
going on well i say that i mean if you
if you held it loosely it might move
around as much as we see here but it
seems a little exaggerated unless i'm
having an off day this is in five five
six it's not 762 and there's a heck of a
lot of recoil for what really ought not
to be i mean the wooden furniture
probably isn't that heavy it's not going
to add appreciably too sort of all up
weight of the thing to reduce felt
recoil so and it's got a fair old chunky
barrel on there so i wouldn't expect it
to recoil that much
this is a russian revolver shotgun and
as the appearance might clear you into
is in fact a hunting weapon designed as
a hunting weapon they did come out with
a tactical version in black with a with
adjustable star or folding stock i think
it was but it is by and large a sporting
weapon revolver revolvers generally
revolver shotguns specifically are
limited in capacity inherently by having
a cylinder but it does have the
advantage that we clearly see
illustrated here of being able to load
in this case up to five different types
of ammunition one in each chamber which
takes full advantage of the game's
ammunition system and is very cool i
quite like the fist full of shells there
that's quite cool and the way they um
they sort of slide out the cylinder and
tumble to the floor is really quite
satisfying as well i did see the the
phrase double action pop up there so it
seems that you can toggle between double
and single action which i'm sure you
know but in simple terms means on double
action you pull through on the trigger
and it [ __ ] and fires on single action
you have to manually cop the hammer the
reason for doing that would be precision
so if you're trying to shoot out to
maximum effective range of maybe 50
meters with this uh well no it's not
fair possibly possibly longer than that
ideally you probably wouldn't want to
engage beyond 50 but you might well want
to [ __ ] the hammer to reduce the
pressure on the on the main spring and
give you a lighter bigger pull so you're
disturbing your shot less that's the
whole point of single action as an
option uh most games don't let you do
that this one does
very cool revolver design choice of a
revolver well
as we've spoken about before revolvers
are pretty ob well i know i'll get flak
if i say they're obsolete but in the
broadest in the broad picture they are
um why have six rounds when you can have
17 20 or more
in the in the 2020s revolvers are not a
great choice for much at all but you
know variety and all that um and the
game this game allows you to use
different types of ammunition which does
add a little bit to the relevance of a
revolver in that you can carry a mixed
cylinder i'm not sure you see much
difference between jacketed hollow
points and full metal jackets say i'm
certain that they've modeled the
difference in terms of will it penetrate
soft body armor versus will it cause a
bit you know more damage to the npc bar
or whoever uh behind the armor i'm sure
it's all modeled but at the power level
if you like of a handgun that's going to
be much less evident and trying to
manage a mixed cylinder of ammunition on
a on a handgun revolver as it were as
opposed to a revolver shotgun or
something not really worth the squeeze
i don't think one minor point as well
the ability to pull out individual
rounds without using the ejector rod i'm
dubious about especially with gloves on
there's you just don't have enough like
you have to get your fingernail behind
the rim
and is there any real benefit to
selectively loading the cylinder rather
than just
bombing it up with six shots and
shooting them down range
your mileage may vary
so this is the hk g28 uh helpfully
written on the side in case i didn't
know
this is another this is a another gucci
weapon that i'd be a little skeptical
that somebody in this
environment would be able to even get
their hands on but it's a very faithful
representation as far as i know of the
real rifle you know you'll notice some
very literally in your face branding on
the optical sight on this gun schmidt
and bender very famous uh telescopic
sight maker uh they made the the optics
for the l96a1 for example uh but it
actually set explicitly four hk on the
side of this so this is this is a
another six for a situation where a a
complete weapon system if you like has
been put together by a manufacturer
involving subcontractor companies so
that you're offering the complete
solution to the military service that's
buying the weapon and that would include
in this case the suppressor as well
probably even your vertical grip only
thing and i won't say letting it down
because i i can see the reason for it
gameplay-wise but the suppressor is
heating i'm gonna go out my limb and say
too rapidly it's visibly glowing red
after a admittedly a rapid string of
shots but this is not capable of
automatic fire in the in reality or in
the game i just think that's heating up
too quickly but how do you have that
visual indicator of it heating
[Music]
all right we have another doohickey here
afraid i don't know the model of it but
um it is a laser rangefinder and at one
point we have a visible laser as well
but it looks like that's that's
toggleable you don't need me to explain
what's going on here i don't think but
it's reading around about 200 meters at
one point and the players adjusted their
bullet drop compensator on their scope
to 200 meters which means that the point
of impact point of view is going to
consider coincide pretty much with the
point of impact which is the whole point
of being able to adjust the scope now if
you didn't have the rangefinder you'd
have to estimate range which i think is
probably harder in a game than it is in
real life because unless you're in v
well even if you are in vr it's very
hard to gauge the distance you can range
from you know the average height of a
man or other ways to do it but uh given
that this is a set in the present day or
near future actually come to think of it
probably it's really nice that they are
implementing up-to-date technology
what's really moving forward uh
are
electro-optical sites of various types
and even this is a little bit old hat by
the
state-of-the-art cutting edge where
you've got a site that's that's
not quite thinking for you but
getting in that direction
oh dave what have you done to this poor
innocent glock 18 at its heart however
it's one of these glock 18 c the c
stands for compensated and here is ours
or one of ours in its original
tupperware style container
with with the markings on it which is
very nice so when people call the glock
tactical tupperware they're not just
referring to the plastic frame well they
might be but
it actually does come in tupperware
now from what i can see under all of
this nonsense it's it's a good
representation of an 18c uh now i can't
uh hope to replicate the dubious uh
creation scene here but i happen to have
a surefire
light module here very simply fits to
the accessory rail and makes
this one look a little bit more like the
one in the game now uh a
light and a and in this case laser
module a very sensible accessory for a
modern combat pistol fully automatic
automatic capability and 50 round run
less so
quite a graphic illustration there of
why automatic fire on a rifle is getting
on for pointless let rip on automatic
and your first shot will be on target
the rest will be over the over the
target's head most likely with a
cartridge like 762 by 39 that the coil's
relatively hard for for its power level
if that makes sense to you and the
general configuration of the ak is not
ideal for recoil control partly why they
went to the ak74 with the much flatter
shooting lower recoiling
5.45 cartridge now this particular ak
pretty sure i wouldn't have spotted this
to be honest is a rifle dynamics variant
of the ak now that's a u.s company so
it's quite surprising to see it modeled
in a game that's set in eastern europe
where of course there are lots
of aks not sure why you would do that i
guess if you were a private military
contractor bringing your weapons to that
to the country that you're going to be
fighting in or operating in you might
bring in bring western aks i think
that's pretty unusual i think they're
typically bought at least
regionally if not nationally and
supplied there because nothing else
transporting prohibited weapons often
across borders is a massive pain anyway
this is i'm analyzing this in far too
much detail
uh it's it's just in the game to be an
interesting modernized variant of an ak
and it does that job
absolutely love that feature it's not
just for immersion it's gameplay
relevant and it's completely realistic
as well so the the player has is either
choosing to not use a magazine to show
me this feature or has has no magazines
in the inventory but is still able to
use the gun
99 of games if you even model the
ability to
load magazines with ammunition which is
extremely rare anyway what i don't think
would include
this realistic feature which is as you
can see and you've probably seen this
done with shotguns where you load in a
single round into an open
ejection port of course you can do that
with a rifle as well before we had
magazine rifles we had single shot
rifles and it's perfectly possible to
use a modern rifle in that way albeit
it's harder to do because they're not
designed for that purpose whereas
traditional single shot rifles like the
martini henry for example or mauser 71
you open the bolt put the round on a
nice flat tray close it up and
designed to feed in that way a magazine
rifle is designed to use the magazine
follower as that platform so when you
don't have a magazine if you try to just
insert the loose round it will fall
through the bottom of the magazine oh
sorry out of the magazine well hence the
players having to sort of finagle it
into position and sort of help guide it
in but perfectly doable and exactly what
you would have to do or i guess draw a
knife or something but i'd rather have a
single shot rifle than revert to
close combat
fn scar i think you probably know the
history of the scar um from previous
videos if not from from other sources
special forces combat assault rifle is
the um slightly hilarious attempt at a a
macho name for the gun by means of
acronym this is a
a good version i have one
on my lap as you do identical to the one
in the game except that uh this is the
short barrel obviously and the one in
the game is fitted with the full length
barrel and ours has the fn 40 gl
grenade launcher you've probably seen
this on on this series before
grenade launcher
that mounts to
the picatinny rail on the bottom of the
gun take the cycle as well
and that gives us something a bit closer
to what we see here
at least allows me to compare it a bit
better for for nerding out purposes and
from what i can see all of the right
angles and surfaces are represented but
yeah i'd have to i've had i'd have to
work very hard to find any issues with
this um i noticed that we have a black
cheek piece on on here um the standard
version that matches the gun just only
has a black button
this is entirely black that's probably
from the customization process but i
mean just just to show how spot on this
is the markings there are
represented exactly we even have an l
series serial number on ours
that's in the 14 000 range and the gun
in the game is in the 900 sorry the 99
100 000 range
990 000 range to use proper english so
these are you know this is like the
virtual brother to the real one that i'm
holding
another difference i've noticed actually
there's the stock scar at least when we
got all of this uh came with a an a2
ar15
pistol grip and the one in the game has
a magpul pistol grip fitted to it i'm
not sure if that's a player changed
thing or if the scar comes with that as
standard but it's the whole point of
this lower receiver was to mimic the
ar-15 as much as possible in terms of
muscle memory for the troops that would
be using it and in terms of
compatibility with
magazines pistol grips
different derivatives this is a very
distant derivative of the ar-15 really i
certainly wouldn't call it an ar-15 but
they've tried to retain as much of it as
they can
whilst moving things forward as it were
or going sideways depending on your
point of view
[Music]
those were more guns from the excellent
tarkov if you'd like to support us here
at the royal armouries museum um best
way to do that is to visit us if you
possibly can we've got some events going
on this summer also worth mentioning i
think um the journal that i'm associate
editor of the armax journal that's the
journal of the cody firearms museum who
are good friends of ours as well has a
new issue out it's a second issue from
the revived run please do check that out
it is paid for but i like to think it's
worth it
otherwise guys we'll see you again next
time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you